Skateboarding was my salvation
and my way of having fun.
JAY DUPLASS:
This film is really about Tony
and what's really going on
inside of him.
He had to reinvent skating.
Make some noise for Tony Hawk!
(CROWD CHEERS)
I've been trying to make
this film for a long time.
Sam pitches this idea of doing
the epic Tony Hawk documentary.
We both said,
"Yes, this is amazing."
And then we're off and running.
It's a much deeper story,
and stuff that I've never
really shared at all.
There is some footage in here
I had no idea existed.
♪ (INTENSE MUSIC PLAYING) ♪
He is a beast who is just
gonna skate no matter what.
Tony Hawk is the reason
I started skateboarding.
Tony Hawk is just a legend.
It takes a lot of dedication
to do what he does,
and it's really inspiring.
Family is hugely important
to Tony.
It was beautiful to put
that part of his life into film,
and not just make it
about skating.
I feel like if I'm able
to stand on my own two feet,
I'm gonna ride a skateboard.
I'm not gonna quit doing it.